hi everyone it's Charlie hopefully you
guys have had a chance to see the Game
of Thrones finale by now this is just
gonna dig a little bit deeper into
what's going on in the finale and some
of the big questions that they answered
and what I think is going to be
different in George RR Martin's A Song
of Ice and Fire book ending some things
will be the same from a plot perspective
but some things will be very different
so I'll try to explain as we go through
these big beats if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the game of Thrones
Song of Ice and Fire videos I'll start
talking about the prequel later this
week - but there's still a lot of
finales stuff that we have to unpack
about the main series we'll do a new
round of the HBO now giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment about the finale on
the video obviously careful for spoilers
for everything that happened in the game
of Thrones finale but starting with
number 10 brands new six kingdoms so
brains are broken in his new realm I do
like the jokes that means I've been
seeing about bran being the villain of
the story because he did very little in
terms of actually helping people
involved win the Iron Throne he just
served as bait for the night king and
told them the story of what the night
king was after and how he was this
living memory of everything did you sort
of chilled out in the north while
everybody fought with each other when he
actually claims that he saw this
happening in the future he knew that
they would ask him to become King so why
didn't he say anything does that make
him kind of a villain yes and no he's
more ambiguous is more of a gray area
just because he's not good he's not evil
he lost a lot of his humanity but it
seems like he does still have a sense of
humor but he's basically the Westerosi
equivalent of the Internet now near
omniscience so he is a very powerful
person the show did not do a great job
of getting that across he has she has
way more abilities than you saw him use
on the TV show but his first act as king
as they say at the end of the episode in
that final scene with him is to rebuild
the realm aka bran the Builder or brand
the broken builder in pursuit of that
he'll be using his perfect recall and
everyone's secrets against them from a
political perspective to keep any new
Littlefinger hopefuls from dear ailing
any economic and political stability in
the realm
he'll also probably help fact check the
collective knowledge of the Citadel with
the grand maester Sam wells help at some
point when he says they need a new
master of whispers master of war and
master of laws they don't have a lot of
good options in terms of who's left
alive in terms of show characters for
master
whispers but they could always look east
to any Westerosi Nobles that have been
living in disgrace and exile after
Robert's rebellion to bring back to
become their new master of war otherwise
I would say bran would probably be their
best option but for some weird reason
they made him master of coin as for
master of laws that's not quite as big
of a position so really anyone with the
requisite legal experience would
probably be fine the last thing the
brand mentions in the episode is that
he'll use his abilities to accurately
locate drogon who they say was last seen
headed east
they don't say where exactly because
they cut Samwell off but I think that
they're winking at the idea that drogon
is headed back to the ruins of ancient
Valyria in the Valyrian Peninsula big
question how closes brands ending him
becoming King - George are Martens
intended book ending I'll say brain is
still probably going to become king but
the way that they arrive at that
decision will probably make a lot more
sense just because you have POV chapters
bran is a very central character in
George R Martin's story but the TV show
hasn't done a great job of utilizing him
he even sat out all of season five so in
the books bran is just a much more
active participant in the stuff that's
going on in the story number nine brands
new small council so Tyrion his hand of
the king Samwell is his grand maester
Breanna's Commander of the Kingsguard
Davos is master of ships and bran
mysteriously has become master of coin
their first act is to obtain financing
to rebuild King's Landing bran
preferring that they start with the
brothels Davos preferring that they
start with the port and the new fleet of
ships they'd call back to Tyrians
childhood he tasks Samwell with
upgrading the sewer system in King's
Landing
which is probably one of the smartest
things that Tyrion will be remembered
for after he dies because that's really
huge in terms of preventing a lot of
easily avoidable diseases and illnesses
in a population maybe then they'll write
a book about Tyrion and the amazing
sewer system that he was responsible for
they're also in the process of
rebuilding the red keep obviously but it
seems like bran will always use his
favorite chair that he's specially made
for himself after Tarr Garen design to
be his permanent throne so to speak you
can't steal the throne from brand if he
always takes the throne with him
wherever he goes
how close was the ending for all these
characters to the books though Tyrion is
probably still gonna wind up being
handed the King just because he's such
an important character from a POV
perspective Samwell eventually becoming
grand mace
even if it's not right away feels
relatively accurate maybe he just goes
back and finishes his training as a
Meister then brand names him as his
grand maester big change though I don't
think that bran is gonna be a big part
of this book ending I think that he was
only involved in this scene because he's
such a popular TV show character so this
way there was so much extra bronze stuff
seemingly going on the last couple of
seasons
I don't know that Davos is gonna wind up
being on this small Council either in
the books because Liam Cunningham has
just been a really popular character
amongst the producers in the cast and
the fans so they just keep bringing him
back and giving him an even bigger role
so I don't think he'll be quite so big
in the books
number 8 Sansa becomes queen of the
North when she permanently annexes it
and that also includes everything north
of the wall as well including the lands
of always winter her first act will be
to name new Lords to the last hearth to
replace the umbers to Bear Island to
replace the Mormont's and then they'll
just slowly rebuild the parts of the
north that were destroyed by the White
Walkers or the war with the Bolton's in
the castles like Winterfell rebuilding
their forces I think part of the logic
of Sansa wanting to annex the north was
to prevent them from being forced into
any subsequent words that Westeros gets
involved in involving the throne or any
southern conflicts and even though brand
controls the wall as king really the
responsibility for supplying the newly
reformed Nights Watch will fall on her
as she's the closest noble usually the
king looks to the warden of the north to
manage the wall and then they'll
petition the crown for any extra
reinforcements or supplies if they need
it
I know you're asking why do they need a
Night's Watch if there are no more White
Walkers I think the idea is that is just
sort of a catch-all for people that
don't want to live out their lives in a
Cell it is an option for Nobles with
situations like samwell's where you have
a succession issue with a younger son
that the Lord wants to pass his title to
but really their duty now is more as a
glorified chain-gang I don't know if
they're gonna repair that part of the
wall that fell down you did you need
Giants to help out with that supposedly
it was bran the Builder working with
Giants with the children of the forest
using magic to help build the wall so I
think for the most part because there's
no real threat north of the wall right
now they'll just continue to be a very
small glorified police group in that
area in the far north
if Sansa chooses to take a husband there
are several eligible bachelors in
Westeros now amongst the nobles but I'm
sure sweet Robin is going to try and
throw his hat in the ring
several more times as they grow older
but I expect her to eventually take a
northern husband over a South Ron one I
don't expect her to ever get married to
Gendry or anything like that like she
said though it probably wouldn't have
worked out between her and tyrion tyrion
himself is also free to get married
again if he ever falls in love in tyrion
is now de facto Lord of Casterly Rock
warden of the West and the tallest
lannister for the most part I think that
sonses ending is pretty accurate to the
books I do think that eventually she'll
sort of become the new Catelyn Stark
lady of the north and manage everything
although I'm not expecting book Sansa to
annex the north that might just be a TV
show thing 7 Arya's adventures in the
western hemisphere
so despite arya saying that no one knows
what's west of Westeros there are
historical records of people from the
Western continent beyond the sunset sea
sailing to the Iron Islands tens of
thousands of years ago becoming the
progenitors of the Ironborn but that's
about it we just have vague records of
people from the West sailing to Westeros
a long long time ago I wouldn't be
surprised if one of the prequel shows is
set there there were hints that george
RR martin that he might do some sort of
aria sequel story at some point about
her continuing adventures in an adult
after the events of the main novels so
aria is ending traveling away setting
off for adventure feels fairly accurate
to the books that line what's west of
Westeros is a TV show thing it's not a
book thing so she might just go back to
Braavos or the East somewhere to six the
unsullied in the Dothraki go their
separate ways as grey worm says the
unsullied are traveling to miss anne
days home of naath down there to protect
her people from slavers or anyone that
might seek to do them harm
the Dothraki seem like they're headed
back east to resume what they were doing
before Daenerys killed all the cows just
continuing to rule in the great grass
sea but maybe a few them decide to stay
in Westeros to settle in the reach but
the book ending for these characters
will probably be a little bit different
and then most of them will just travel
back east five Croghan flies away with
Daenerys his body is most likely that he
took her body back to Dragonstone the
caves were the old Targaryen dragons
were hatched and roosted are still there
so he probably took her body there then
headed east towards Essos
I think they're winking at the idea of
him going back to the ruins of the 14
flames in ancient Valyria like we saw
him flying overhead in that region
during season 5 when Tyrion and Jorah
were sailing through ancient Valyria
it's really hard to say how act
this is going to be to his bookending
drogon just flying off to live free for
the rest of his life does feel like a
book thing but I don't know if he would
carry Daenerys his body away like that
and I don't know that he would
immediately burn the Iron Throne I like
the joke that drogon sees the pointy
knife sticking out of Daenerys and then
sees all the pointy things sticking out
of the Iron Throne thinking that the
Iron Throne was responsible for killing
Daenerys what might wind up happening in
the books though is that Daenerys winds
up using drogon to melt the Iron Throne
or if it's not melted by drogon then
bran and any other survivors the new
small Council wind up melting it down
symbolically destroying it but Bor Jamie
and Cersei dying together when Daenerys
destroys part of the red keep this is
probably gonna be very different in the
books I'm expecting more of a payoff for
the valonqar prophecy for Jaime so maybe
in the books they still wind up dying
together but Jaime is more responsible
for her death but book Jaime was always
probably going to eventually go back to
Cersei it's just that he was gonna stay
with Brienne for a much much longer
period in the books before he goes back
the part about the valonqar prophecy
about a younger Queen coming to take all
that Cersei holds dear will still also
probably be Daenerys in the books and
not Margaery just like the TV show 3ds
and airs sack in King's Landing and
turning into another tyrant just like
her father the Mad King this is another
one of those things that I feel like is
fairly accurate to the books but the way
they get her there how and why she turns
will be very different a much clearer
progression from well-meaning ingenue
warrior Queen Daenerys to full-blown Mad
Queen Daenerys after she's lost
everything that she holds dear so book
Daenerys will also probably lose wriggle
in Viserion all the people around her
that she really cares about that have
been helping advise her this whole time
book Jon Snow will still probably wind
up killing her fulfilling the Nissa
Nissa part of the azure high prophecy
sort of paying off the john prince who
was promised a Song of Ice and Fire the
reason why people think that this is
going to be the book ending is is
because when Martin told Dan and Dave
about what his planned ending for the
books was he told them three big WTF
moments that they could use to benchmark
their series as big signposts the first
thing he told them was about Jon Snow
being resurrected the second thing he
told them was about how Hodor got his
name remember home
the door then they said that they would
never reveal what the third thing Martin
told them was because it was from the
very end of the story and that was
probably about Daenerys turning into the
mad Queen and going completely off the
rails with Jon Snow having to kill her
so number two the war with the White
Walkers in the books will also probably
go down very differently there is no
night king yet in Martin's books it's
possible that he could introduce some
sort of prime white Walker but it's more
likely that the war for the dawn will be
more of a collective effort with the
characters wielding Valyrian swords
being more responsible for taking down
each of the separate White Walkers and
even though Arya Stark has really
important skills and will probably kill
a white Walker she by herself will not
zero them out single-handedly and the
White Walkers will also probably not
bring down the wall with an undead
dragon it'll probably be the Horn of
winter as described in the books the way
they've been teasing that number one of
course though Jon Snow takes the black
as penance for regicide killing the
Queen and goes back to the wall this is
another one of those events in the books
that I think will be similar but the
reason why he goes back to the north
will probably be very different this
gets more into Martin's planned
bittersweet ending talking about Tolkien
so Martin has said that his ending in
the books will be very reminiscent of
Tolkien's ending for the Lord of the
Rings when you examine it through that
lens Jon Snow is basically the Frodo of
the series like I said he has almost
more POV chapters than any other
character besides tyrion so the story is
basically about Jon Snow
he's Frodo he destroys the One Ring in
fire basically him killing Daenerys then
like Frodo suffers wounds through the
course of his journey that will never
heal fully remember when torment slapped
Jon Snow when they were all having
drinks in Episode four and he winced in
pain that's because a lot of his stab
wounds from when he was resurrected have
not fully healed so just like Frodo he
to boards a boat at the end to go back
to his version of the Grey Havens which
is essentially the wall in the Nights
Watch there was a lot of confusion about
that final scene with him taking the
wildlings north of the wall with ghosts
here's the thing about that there was a
big speech that John had quoting maester
aemon talking about how duty and honor
were the death of love would you choose
honor and Duty over someone that you
loved Jon Snow chooses his duty to the
realm over his love for Daenerys that's
why he killed her
because he had this staunch Ned Stark
level honor till the very end
so if honor and Duty were such an
important foundation for his character
along every step of the way then I don't
think that he suddenly take the Night's
Watch vows to serve and protect the
realm father no children to then turn
right around in his final scene and
abandon his honor by deserting the
Nights Watch so I think all he's doing
in this final scene here is just helping
take the wildlings back north of the
wall to reclaim the far north because
there's no more White Walkers so there's
no threat to them so they have all this
territory to settle in again after that
he'll probably just come back and
continue to man the Nights Watch as the
one-thousandth Lord Commander but I
never expected to have like a really
huge Nights Watch anymore unless they
just suddenly have this proliferation of
criminals that they don't want to throw
in prison but if you have any other big
questions about the finale or things
that happened at the end that I didn't
answer in this video let me know in the
comments I am doing a finale Q&A video
in the next day or two so leave all your
questions that you want me to include on
that on this video there'll be a couple
more bonus videos this week I'll talk
about the Game of Thrones prequel and
then don't forget there's gonna be a
bonus episode of Game of Thrones next
Sunday I'll do a video for that too if
you're wondering what's coming next
obviously there's the Game of Thrones
prequel which is supposed to premiere
sometime next year
there's His Dark Materials The Watchmen
series coming later this year the Amazon
Lord of the Rings TV series which might
start next year then The Witcher Netflix
series which I'll also be doing videos
for so all those things that I just
talked about I'll be doing videos for
that stuff I'll do trailer videos for
that stuff as we start to get new
footage there was also a new Westworld
season 3 trailer so if you do have any
requests leave them in the comments
below
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big video to léopold please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details while you wait
for everything click here for my Game of
Thrones Season 8 finale video and Easter
eggs
and click here for my Watchmen HBO
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight